im berliner stadtteil kreuzberg ist es
im rahmen der revolutionären erster mai
demonstrationen am frühen dienstag abend
zu auseinandersetzungen zwischen
teilnehmern und der polizei gekommen
[Applaus]
mehrere demonstranten wurden
festgenommen
zuvor hatten laut polizei
einsatzeinheiten dem demonstrationszug
den weg versperrt um zu verhindern dass
der aufzug in den bereich des
sogenannten maifest läuft ein jährlich
am ersten mai stattfindende straßenfest
in kreuzberg die zugänge zum görlitzer
park waren bereits am nachmittag wegen
überfüllung geschlossen worden
rund 1500 teilnehmer sollen laut polizei
zu der demonstration gestartet sein
über die streckenführung hatte es bis
zuletzt und klarheit gegeben